genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by Mint mobile my friends
is saving money is on your 2024 list
your odds aren't looking great luckily I
have 100% guaranteed way to save you
money this year and I only say your odds
aren't looking great because on average
it takes about 30 days for a person to
break their New Year's resolution
mmobile is here to rescue with premium
Wireless plans for just 15 bucks a month
use your own phone with any mmobile plan
and bring your phone number along with
all your existing contacts to get this
new customer offer and your new 3month
unlimited wires plan for just 15 bucks a
month go to mobile.com genius5 that's
mobile.com genius5 cut your wireless
build at 15 bucks a month at mobile.com
genius5 additional taxes fees and
restrictions appli to mmobile for
details genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by Magic mind
how do you feel right now do you feel
mentally wide awake and Ultra productive
without the Jitters of drinking too much
coffee bet you don't cuz you're not
taking magic mind it's what I start my
day with especially when I podcast
before I podcast I take a quick shot of
this and I am good to go best thing
about it there's no crash and on top of
that not only does it give you an energy
boost it gives you a whole bunch of
other stuff and specifically I'm talking
about the ashwag gandha and the lines
made inside it so if you guys don't know
what liines man does it supports
attention and cognitive processing and
working memory it also has organic
ashwaganda which supports the reduction
of Stress and Anxiety which is amazing
so if you guys want to cop yourself some
magicmine go to magic mind.com and or
order yourself some today you will not
create regret it it's magic mind.com and
then she's doing a little dirty talk and
then I tell a joke I was like oh yeah
your triceps are so [__] sexy and she
went no oh my God no and she pushed me
off and rolled over sometimes the jokes
are worth it 5 4 3 2 1 what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we are the
podcast to be with you where every you
are out in this world go ahead and share
us so other people can laugh and have a
good [__] time if you don't hey man
you're going to hell and we have Ed Park
VP recurring recurring co-host um
obviously New Year's just passed
Christmas just passed last episode we
talked about literally it was basically
my therapy session of the [__] it was
my therapy too but the [__] eight
days of just absolute [__] torture
did you did you uh celebrate New Year's
yes luckily or the new year which I
figured out it's not happy New Year's
it's happy New Year yeah that's what I I
didn't know that assumed I mean how many
years are there I know it's like the
dumbest thing like somebody made fun of
me they're like New Years I'm like yeah
[__] what it's like it's happy New Year
and then I stopped and I'm like oh my
God my why there is no s at the end of
it that doesn't [__] dramatically
doesn't yeah I had no [__] idea I
just found out this year Merry
Christmases yeah happy happy birthdays
happy
Halloween I'm just gay happy
Halloween Happy New Year's Merry
Christmas is yeah that's maybe that's
probably where you picked it
up but uh yeah I saw um I saw the boy in
the Heron oh um what did you think so I
went in super excited and then cuz I
went with s and Stevie and then I
realized they bought the Japanese
language movie I wanted to see the
Hollywood a-lists do the voices me yeah
I know this is controversial with anime
I like dub oh really I'm a dub guy you
know why cuz I love watching the
animation I'm sick and tired of reading
[__] when there's like animation
happening I'm a big fan of the drawings
illustrations so for me I'm a big fan of
dub except one punch man it's the worst
dub I've heard yeah but um yeah so we go
in there and as we're watching it for me
I'm a little annoyed because I got to
read and I can't see the animation which
by the way was [__] amazing yeah like
Disney Disney has never and could never
just won't I mean you know the thing
about like the boy and the Heron 2o or
just any kind of um Miyazaki film is
that you could technology can get as
great as it is right but the thing about
what 3D technology is trying to is
trying to replicate real life right and
you're trying to replicate something
that already exists with 2D there is no
limits yep right and I'm not talking
about stuff like uh Ninja Turtles or you
know cross the spiderverse cross SP
those two movies are the ones that are
that are going to issue like in a new
decade of really great aesthetically
different animations cuz for the past 20
years every [__] 3D animated movie
looks the same exactly that's why they
call him all Pixar even if it's made by
Dreamworks right so I'm really glad with
the direction that Hollywood's going
with that anyway sorry yeah and you know
like 2D films like specifically if you
guys go to Japan and you go to just if
you walk by a theater half the movie
posters are animation films animation
films it's it's really integrated into
the culture right which I was actually
shocked about so when I and obviously
everybody's getting really excited to
see any type of Miyazaki film yeah and
you know he never fails like it's it's
just a it's like it's literally moving
art yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
it like the amount of detail and the
frame by frame like animations they do
like the [__] um when his dreams when
the fires are coming up that's [__]
handdrawn yeah that's so insane yeah and
while I was appreciating all of that and
having to read yeah I got lost I can't
understand story oh for me maybe it's
because I've only watched sub so I I
read pretty fast too so I could like
scan and then look up scan look up but
um sometimes for me when I listen to
dubb because there are things in
language that doesn't translate very
well right and so when it becomes dubbed
it things I get even more distracted
because it sounds off right something's
not right it's not matching up to the
movements and what they're doing and
they're doing their the best that they
can and I think it's decent um the only
dubbed Miyazaki film that I enjoyed was
actually uh princess manoke princess
manoke was the only one that I Eno
that's also one of Mian zaki's films
that could literally be like action I
wish there live action version of that
it really [__] could but you know
what it is that I actually realized that
I enjoyed about um boy Heron was when I
walked in and I learned it was sub I was
a little iffy because here's another
controversial take I'm not a fan of
Kabuki theater oh really I don't like
that style of of acting now it's
cultural that is Japanese style acting
but there you're not going to meet a
Japanese person that talks that way yeah
yeah they do you know
the when they get mad they hold their
tongue yeah and then and then when I saw
B the Heron sub it was like they weren't
doing that they were acting voice acting
and it was just them being real and then
I saw Godzilla minus one which is a damn
near Perfect film yeah but why it's not
that great for me I couldn't stand
acting yeah it's the Kabuki theater
aspect of it I felt like if you acted
more realistic I felt like I could have
been drawn in towards the emotions it
felt hand fisted because of the big face
emotional acting and the loud voices
that so like to put it in perspective
for people like imagine you guys
watching uh single cam a single cam
series but they're acting as if they're
doing multi-cam acting and that's what
it feels like you know for that Kabuki
Stella what the from Old Stage Theater
they're old they had operas and such
right and but they that's the thing with
theater so you go to Shakespearean in
England and it's the same they'll tell
you to Big make big faces loud voice
make big gestures because back in the
day it was just one person on this giant
stage right no PA system or none of that
right and so but the thing is like
Hollywood you know they used to talk
like this and right yeah yes over time
it evolved because it was just more
accepted to be grounded and realistic
right and and Korea adopted that as well
Korea has like a their own version of
Kabuki it's in K dramas yes yeah so if
you watch Korean films and you see a
create drama and they act completely
differently yeah it's that one or the
other Kabuki theater such so even
reminds me of like um The Last Samurai
Cruz I I mentioned it a couple weeks ago
one of my favorite
movies when the Japanese actors are
speaking English to Tom Cruz great
acting they're great all of them great
actors and then when they're talking to
each other and all of a sudden they
start acting differently in Kabuki
theater and yeah I'm like I get thrown
off of that yeah so that is kind of like
where I was sitting with Godzilla minus
one near perfect I just wish it was
better acting but you got to see and
you'll see this with a lot of
adaptations right uh specifically anime
adaptations you you have real human
beings here yeah but then they have
plastic wigs on you know what I mean and
then how they react they're also trying
to create this very specific humor that
you see in 2D animation and it's allowed
to be exaggerated because of the like
all these stars are popping out or
whatever and it makes sense it's very
jarring when you see that with people
right it it's so [__] weird and look
I know a while back we were supposed to
do that one piece review oh yeah I
forgot but then lo and behold the former
Studio that I was with lost it all so we
actually did review it we reviewed it
and it was it was gone it's all gone
right and I don't even know the stuff
that we talked about anymore because we
watched it so far back yeah um I don't
know if we should even talk about now do
you even remember the show yeah or the
things I said about it it was basically
we talked about how they had that wide
angle lens that okay well let's let's
talk about it just because I feel like
I've had enough so when these things
happen right this happened to me twice
it happened with a Batman review M and
it happened with one piece right and I
get so pissed because I don't think
people understand when you guys ask us
to do movie which I really enjoy it
takes a lot of time you know like for me
to sit and watch something two or three
times get my notes right and kind of
like get hyped up about the things I
want to talk about and then to do that
again is very hard it's hard right kind
of sucks you know how long the Batman is
yeah for me to watch that twice this
watch it three times yeah in theaters in
theaters it was exhausting you know but
I have to watch it twice cuz I watch
Once to enjoy and second time I try to
see what I'm looking for or what I want
to see in it right and it's so difficult
look a lot of people liked the one like
the one piece Series right so much in
fact that is having a second season with
almost like twice the budget or
something good for them right I guess I
forgot how much it was per episode but
it was like $2 million an episode or
something really the budget was for this
one that came out it was really [__]
high so okay let's talk about the stuff
that I enjoyed about it it's probably
one of the better liveaction anime
series that I've seen in a long time now
a lot of people that you know some of
the stuff that people disliked I kind of
disagreed with like there were some
people complaining about um who the the
casting for people right but people also
forget that when you know just because
you see things in anime and everybody
speaking Japanese they're not all
Japanese right right right cuz Luffy is
from Brazilian yeah he's Brazilian so
they I think they casted really really
well um the issue that I always have
with these series specifically when it
came
to uh the one piece series is I [__]
hated the costume design and look
whoever was the costume design I'm
pretty sure you had to make do with
which I mean this is something it's
still very new and nobody has done it
that well costume designing anime is so
ult because this [__] is weird as
[__] nobody dresses like this nobody
looks like this and they're supposed to
make it look right and I know they do
that in like Marvel films right where
everything's but they don't have
Marvel's budget or even if they did they
they're whoever does Marvel [__] is
really [__] good yeah and it's not
just the costume it's the way that it's
everything done in post to make it look
that way right which they didn't do here
right so when you have somebody like
Luffy where he's wearing this bright red
vest and these pants it all just looks
like one solid color yes very solid
colors throughout no texture no nothing
you know what I'm saying and that to me
was very very jarring the wigs plastic
looking as [__] it looked like an anime
convention yeah it was cosplay right and
I'll tell you this there's probably
cosplay people that could have done it
better yes way better yeah and I've seen
it right so when I look at this and it
just it looked like a
fanmade film yeah right and I was
expecting more from it and then I don't
know though like when when you say
fan-made film but it sometimes it feels
like are the creators fans of the show
yeah right now that's a just a genuine
question for me oh we don't know right
we don't know yeah um because I didn't
grow up watching One Piece uh after
Dragon Ball I just kind of gave up on it
and then um so this came out and I and I
this is the my first experience with one
piece and for me it's just okay
accepting it for what it is in live
action which which was fine but then um
yeah I don't know it I don't know if it
was for me or not like cuz it was there
was a like a Pirates of the Caribbean
Vibe big adventure the Open Seas all of
that right and then it would be like the
Power Rangers yeah with like the fight
scenes or like some of the acting or
such so I felt like maybe it was like it
couldn't really figure out what its
identity was yeah show yeah cuz you have
to make it palatable for the Western
audience
the I mean we could get into this too
right the editing was not very good like
some of the transitions the fight
choreography and look they actually did
you know Justice to a lot of things I
could tell like some of the cast members
were probably fans of the show because
they did some like very unique things
like when they were calling out the the
the attacks and stuff which I thought
was it actually worked kind of well but
there was this one scene that I saw that
bothered me so much it was when Luffy
was fighting um arlong and
in the series arlong is like the
sharkface dude right and there was this
weird transition where he's going to
like pillar to pillar and he like flips
up he's clearly doing a flip and it was
like the 80s thing where where Mr Miyagi
does a flip and a new person pops up I'm
like dude what [__] year am I in
right now what what what is with this
[__] transition and we talked about
this when we talked about it before hey
guy can you use a different lens besides
a [__] 17 mil or like what was that
everything was crazy wide and then they
chove in I think it's because they got
this same DP that did the Umbrella
Academy that dude is just a fan of
[__] white ass lenses and he gets
right up in people's faces with this
wide [__] lens dude and like the the
problem too that I don't know what this
guy was [__] thinking about that is
that if you choose to use shoot in wide
format guess what has to be on point
everything everything you can't hide
[__] yeah right you can't hide the
shitty plastic looking set design right
which by the way the set design was not
very good it was mixed between amusement
park and cartoon yes where it was like
that's that's what I'm saying with the
the identity of this like is it like
Pirates or is it like Power Rangers yeah
you know and like you got to understand
too when you you take a huge risk when
you shoot that [__] wi right which we
we'll get into the other issue why why
they chose that angle
like World building is very very
important right when you take tight
shots and you kind of just and it's
obviously blur and bokeh obviously adds
like a certain Beauty to it but also
allows like us to hide the mistakes that
we see in the foreground or the
background right and so for example if
you guys watch the series right there's
this part where they're in the navy base
and they're walking down this hallway it
looks like an office space or something
it doesn't look like an like a navy base
like a naval base you know what I'm
saying it just looks like a hallway that
we could have shot anywhere yeah it just
was so bad and also too when they shot
in the in the Town Square where they
were kind when they're trying to free
Zoro it just looked like dirt and
buildings around it could have been shot
anywhere there there wasn't much detail
to that set at all I I don't get and
they spent so much money it's like 2
million an episode or something like
that it was rid where did the [__]
money go it wasn't the costume damn I
mean like like I said for me because it
was my first experience of One Piece I'm
like and then I I went back to watch cuz
Netflix put all a bunch of [__]
episodes of the anime and I'm like dude
I love this [__] but then I'm realizing
yeah the for what it is like the chibi
faces and all that like or those the
things that anime has that makes it
culturally what it is or whatever I I
just don't think it translate live
action like that art is that art it is
that medium for that reason and what
doesn't translate the most is series
that you adapt that's heavily based on
humor
it's very hard to translate a foreign
language humor into another language and
then on top of that because of how
animations like anime specifically does
humor it's not based on the words per se
it's based on the theatrics the Stars
the things coming out somebody drop it's
very Charlie Chaplain right but done in
a exaggerated 2D format how do you get
to translate that to real people right
it's very difficult and by the way just
to go back to the wide lens why the [__]
are you using such a wide perspective on
a single on
somebody what is that they love doing
the spinning [__] I mean like if if it
if the director wanted I mean that's I
don't know what to say honestly it's
just like these are the choices they
made yeah and that's what it is and I I
just want to talk to him like why did
you choose that is it is it something
like I don't get it like I don't
understand the logic behind it and there
are people who don't even watch film and
even they didn't like they're like why
is it I don't understand like they don't
know why they don't like the way it
looks exactly I was watching with my
roommate he grew up on one piece after
the first episode he was just like what
is that called the fish Island yeah he
was bothered by it he was like why do
they keep using that and he was asking
me as like a film question I was like I
don't know dude I hate it too yeah but
like like somebody like that who doesn't
know they just know something is off and
there's something wrong right and so it
kind of makes me wonder like what's with
these choices I think the idea is that
because a wide lens warps you know in in
a certain way especially when you get up
close because it's a cartoon they wanted
to warp their faces a bit and OV
exaggerate these angles you know and
that's for me is a a little lazy yeah
yeah like I mentioned before the
best anime liveaction film is Scott
Pilgrim yeah yeah yeah yeah you know and
it's not even based off an anime but
[__] you know um that's one of my top
10 favorite movies of all time Edgar
right yeah he's just a [__] great
filmmaker and you know how to get it
done yeah you know and and you know you
would see something like Netflix doing
that right uh I mean one piece I can see
them just rushing the [__] out of it
yeah let's go next shot next shot next
shot cuz there's a there's a lot there's
a lot you know packed into these
episodes right so for me it could be
like the rush of it filming everything
as quickly as they can and and you know
like I said a lot of people too will
make the comparison like well is the
best one that's out there doesn't
necessarily mean it's good yeah right
it's a it's a very uh positive way of of
taking yeah like I can get kicked in the
dick or balls both of them suck yeah you
know what are you telling me right now
there I I I've seen tweets are like what
a time to be alive really yeah what a
time to be alive you could say that
about certain Marvel films yeah I could
see that yeah but this like I like I
said it's probably one of the better
ones out there but I still didn't like
it genius brain listeners this podcast
is brought to you by mintmobile on
average it takes about 30 days for a
person to break their New Year's
resolution so if saving money was on
your 2024 list your odds aren't looking
that great luckily I have 100%
guaranteed way to save you money this
year my friends just switch to Mt mobile
for a limited time Wireless plans from
mintmobile are $15 a month when you
purchase a 3-month plan that's unlimited
talk text and data for
$15 a month look we got to save those
Buco bucks baby and mmobile is here to
rescue with premium Wireless plans for
just $15 a month say a bye-bye to your
overpriced Wireless plans jaw-dropping
monthly bills and unexpected overages
what you doing man save that money
there's so many things that you can buy
and pay for an expensive phone bill
because mmobile has your back to get
this new customer offer and your new
three-month Unlimited Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month go to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's mobile.com
genius5 col your wireless build the 15
bucks a month at mobile.com genius5
additional taxes fees and restrictions
apply see mint mobile for details this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends oh my goodness better help
has been sponsoring this podcast for the
longest time why because not only have
they sponsored me I have been using
better heal for a long time and mental
health is mental wealth for those of you
out there who have not tried therapy
it's 2024 baby it's the new year let's
focus on ourselves look maybe you
finally organized one part of your
spaces here now you want to tackle
another one maybe you're taking
supplements every morning and now you
want to actually eat breakfast too well
guess what therapy helps you find your
strength so you can ditch the extreme
resolutions and make changes that really
stick my friends therapy is awesome for
me it gives me an outlet sometimes I
feel like I can't say things even to my
own wife or my personal friends well
guess what I call it my better health
therapist and I feel a lot better man
and guess hey it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge start
therapy with better help celebrate the
progress you've already made visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
genius yeah right if you want to see one
that's that'll make you like this series
go watch the Full Metal Alchemist live
action okay I got it I still haven't
seen it is one of the worst things I've
ever
seen then I don't want to watch that you
have to watch it because just a laugh
cuz Full Metal Alchemist is so humorous
right right half the stuff is humor for
example there's this there's this uh
theme that goes on if you watch uh Full
Metal Alchemist where
um Edward he he's short I've never seen
the show oh so when they make fun of him
right he gets super angry that he's
short and then it exaggerates his head
blows up sharp teeth come out like don't
call me short chibi or whatever whatnot
right they try to replicate that humor
and it's just a person just shaking
going don't call me short and it's so
awkward in English or Japanese in
Japanese Japanese but even in Japanese
it's just terrible but that's what I'm
saying is that's that Kabuki part in
Godzilla minus one there are some scenes
that get utterly ruined by the way the
way these people are acting but then I
realized like the hype behind Godzilla
minus one is because Western audiences
don't know what Kabuki theater is they
just think that's how Japanese people
act yeah and when they go to Japan
they're like a these people are really
quiet yeah they're really quiet they
just go oh so
that's all they
say yeah yeah yeah Japanese people are
more monotone as like a culture
generally right yeah yeah yeah but when
they perform when the camera's on when
when they're dancing when they're
singing dude it is a th% effort that's
Kabuki theater yeah yeah that's what
we're kind of used to seeing also too
what I disliked there was a lot of shots
that that made it into one piece that
shouldn't have been there famously I
mean this guy did it on Tik Tok too
where Zoro [__] rolled his sword bent
in half and they left that [__] in there
and we noticed that off jump like I was
like what the [__] you got this plastic
sword and it bends in half and they go
good shot leave in they probably didn't
have another version of that specific
shot so they had to guessing too which
is bad but at the same time like then
take that Netflix money and fix that
[__] like that Chinese kid on his oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah why not that why not
that I mean he boy did it in After
Effects you know so there there are some
things like I've had to do some [__] for
like big ads because someone put like
Gaff tape on the logo right and then the
the network came to me and they were
like the guy's [__] up like can you
remove these I had to go through this
commercial go frame by frame removing
this [__] tape how and nobody's ever
going to notice what I've done yeah and
I saved this that the the whole campaign
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
cuz uh it was a I can't I guess could
talk about it it's been 10 years it was
Dude Perfect oh they were going to get
on top 10 sport on Sports Center wow and
so they made it in collaboration with a
famous sports drink and these guys D
perfect to because it was sponsored by
the sports drink they had they lazily
taped up the logo and then the sports
string company was like we're not going
to we're not going through with this you
put all this tape over it dog frame by
frame by frame by frame cleaning that
[__] up how long did that take
I'm gonna say like 48 Hours God damn
yeah straight that's insane I have like
we have to yeah like or this is [__]
and a lot of people are getting fired
dude that's [__] insane man so those
are the things like in post that [__]
will come up and they're just like got
to you got to do this like you have to
and you're just like [__] I mean it's a
holiday it's the weekend and I mean
editing is a skill and such a craft and
it's so tedious right and I heard like
AI is going to help out a lot with that
type of yes it's already it's it's
already made it a lot easier like I I'll
put this in perspective right so if you
guys go back and you watch this video
that I did uh in Taiwan right and I took
all this equipment I shot everything by
myself I'll never do that [__] again and
they're like oh what Luts did you use
for that I was like there was no Luts
then dog I had to [__] color it
myself right you guys now have this
ability to find other video creators who
have a specific color scheme that's
similar to something that you like and
you slap it on and make Minor
Adjustments um p style yeah it was like
the day after Dan got a red Scarlet
right what a Lut yeah you go back and
watch it it's like Bland as [__] yeah
it's like we keep trying to turn up the
contrast and all that [__] it's like it
was hard for us to figure out back then
yeah it was so difficult we we and now
everything right here all of it yeah you
know I put myself 10 grand in debt for
my camera yeah yeah yeah you know I put
myself in more debt to buy the lettuce
35 to put the SLR lenses I was like we
were Dan and I were the first few in
Seattle to run around with these SLR
lenses on our [__] handicaps and [__]
yeah and you know for like young
creators too right um you know
everybody's thing is that oh I need
better equipment I need better equipment
every person I know that said has been
the worst shooter I've ever seen in my
life cuz they think that the equipment
is going to help them compose shots
better to understand lighting all that
stuff right there you should be able to
shoot great stuff with your phone mhm
right I mean obviously it's going to
look like he shot on a smaller sensor
but if you understand lighting you you
you just you you win lighting and
composition yeah composition is
everything in your hand and like how you
set up the shot and [__] you know like
there was a I forgot what it was I I
just lost my train of
thought yeah but like you know go going
back to that it's like you know when
somebody asked me in a comment it
doesn't irritate me if they go what lens
are you shooting on it doesn't [__]
matter I could tell you what lens I'm
shooting on it's it's a [__] lens ah I
remember Sports Illustrated used to have
this photographer uh who would shoot all
the swimsuit issues every year right but
he got he's getting he's been old now I
think it was this was a story from the
2000s um he's getting old and blind but
they still hire him to shoot all these
swimsuit issues and they're still coming
out and apparently he uses those
disposable cameras on film oh [__] yeah
and because he's blind he just looks at
that little viewfinder from what he sees
and he sees like like shapes right but
as long as he knows that the light is
right and that his shot being set up the
composition is there because it's a
point and shoot disposable it's like
Infinity Focus M just and then he clicks
it and they [__] published that [__]
you know so yeah was it the camera you
know no it's not it's not you know and
like that's like everybody's biggest
hiccup they just always think that they
need something better and better and
better and also too people aren't
realistic that they suck like I don't
know how many times I've seen somebody
come up to me and they're like oh yo
check out my portfol I want to shoot for
you and it's like the worst [__] I've
ever seen in my life and I'm not saying
that in like I'm not you tell them huh
yeah go for it chase your dreams yeah
chase your dreams dude give it a go
right like we have these conversations
it's
like it's hard to tell somebody that
you're not going to make it right and
it's not because you don't have an
ability to get better it's because you
actually just don't care right when I
have conversations with people who want
to go into film and they want to do all
this other stuff if you don't know or
even watch film as much as I do and I
have no inclination to make a film then
what the [__] are you doing right if I
ask somebody who are your favorite
directors and they go I don't know
that's funny right cuz aren't you the
one who wants to be a filmmaker right
what are your what like why did you
choose this lens or why do you like
these lenses why do you like the way
that it looks and you don't even have to
get into the technical aspects of like
equipment and gear some of the people
who I know who shoot the best they don't
know [__] about gear yeah they can't
talk about gear they just go I like the
50 I like the 35 I like this I like the
way this looks I like the why they this
blah blah blah and they'll do it in the
most like rudimentary way possible like
have you seen um wakanda forever uh what
who's the director's name [__] why
are we forgetting this straight from
Oakland [__] oh my God Wheels help us
out here I got you I got you I know this
is so bad feels so bad uh
[Music]
director who
the is going to fruit fail station Ryan
couger Ryan cougler Ryan couler have you
seen Ryan cougler break down uh uh Black
Panther wakanda forever it's the [__]
most hilarious thing ever he goes all
right so you we F to get in here like sh
Baldhead right and he's not talking
about technical aspects but he knows
what he wants to see as a filmmaker
right and I say this because this is the
[__] that I used to like I could talk
about equipment all day who the [__]
cares if you can't shoot right and
that's me that's why I don't shoot
anymore cuz I'm very aware of my
limitations as a as a shooter and so I'm
like okay I'm not trying to go out there
and try to get these big jobs MH you
know like I'll save shooting for my own
[__] you know because that's not my
realm and the other things that you know
I have to figure out what I'm good at in
the realm too so that was another thing
a lot of young kids do I mean it was it
was the way to do it to come up was you
got to be the [__] you got to know
everything yeah about you got to learn
to shoot you got to learn to direct you
got to learn to copyright you got to
learn to edit you got to learn you know
color you got to learn everything you
had to do all of it lighting and all
that stuff so I'd show up to shoots or
sometimes I'd have Dan help me but it
would be us with these giant [__]
bags like hundreds of pounds going out
and shooting [__] right but then I
remember I was at a shoot it was for
Hundai right um and they brought uh the
that porsch SUV with the Big Crane
camera on it they shoot all those like
Batman movies and [__] so that was dope
and I was talking to that guy who who
was renting it out and he was just
watching them making sure it was okay
but he
was uh away from the action and so he
just strikes up a conversation with me
he's like you're you know you're just
getting into this he's like yeah just
came to La he's like so what do you do
and I'm like uh you know I do it all
like I direct shoot it and he's like I
don't want to hear that [__] tell me
what you do yeah yeah yeah and this is
like you know a big white guy who's been
in the business for like 30 years
probably he's like figure it out man he
totally just dismissed me cuz he was
like tell me what you do and he walked
away and I was like oh [__] and so
that's where I was like okay I got to
make a choice like what are my strengths
in this yeah I can't stop I start acting
like I'm the best shooter yeah that I
like I know what I like looking at but
I'm not going to go around and shoot
[__] that I know is not up toart with
anybody other shoot eye that I know
that's like the hard part for me like
when I shoot content like I think I'm so
particular about things and I had this
this huge gap where I know what I want
to see I don't know how to set it up
though and that's where I'm like oh this
is where I don't study enough right
because that's the part that you have to
develop that taste I know what my taste
is I know what I want it to look like
and I should I'm like it doesn't look
like
and then it pisses me off I'm like what
the [__] is happening here and this is
what I learned from being around uh a
friend he he looks at a a monitor and he
doesn't see like the image he sees data
yeah he sees the the the histograms and
all that stuff he sees where the light
goes and all that [__] and then you you
would also know that he's a really super
smart like engineering kind of brain and
um and and just science and chemistry
math and all that [__] too like he looks
at it like science like photons coming
down and bouncing off of different
materials and the reflections that it
makes and all that that's what he's
calculating when he makes his shots so
you can be that who's Crazy technical to
the te who programs everything from the
start and then you have you know just a
blind old man who just he he knows he
knows it's going to come out good hey
man dude he's dude my favorite superhero
dude autism boy yeah he's like he is
literally probably the smartest person I
personally know D you know so funny like
this is years ago listen I don't use
this word anymore right but you know
when you [__] around with your friends
you do some [__] and I actually didn't
know very well at the time and I joke
the way that I joke but we've had good
interactions with each other so there's
this uh Taco spot it was used to be this
dollar Taco spot still around it's like
a150 now inflation whatever still
delicious Avenue 26 I'm driving by I'm
getting my late night tacos like a you
know like a fat ass wood I see driving
in his one week right I looked at him
I'm like I was like nice one
whe but I'm thinking that [__] we have
Rapport yeah but nobody told me like
this guy is different you I mean so he's
he's just like riding in his one he
turns over he just freezes up a little
bit kind of stops I'm like like he's
probably like uh did I just get hate
crime yeah like it's me it's David right
but I don't think he knew how to compute
what was happening and I'm like oh this
is we're different you know it's funny
that you say that about him yeah because
I brought Dan over to Fishbowl not Dan
uh my brother uh to fish bowl and it's
there right and it's not a shoot or
anything we're just chilling and so
they're in the they're in the back and
they just met each other so they're just
talking or whatever and from whatever
conversation I hear I hear go oh like
your
mom and then my brother's just like uh
oh yeah like and then I can see him
tents up and his fist yeah and then he
gets up turns and just like lights a
cigarette and he's shaking right and
then turns and goes home he's like I'm
going to die and I'm like what was that
all about and he's like I don't [__]
know that guy's talking [__] about our
mom what the [__] and I was like godamn
yeah that human he learned that from
you you almost caught him in so much
trouble yeah but I have rapport with
people I thought I had rapport with him
yeah but that's a funny thing like we
had long conversations in our apartment
we talked to each other and so I was
like oh I can call him a know I was like
we're we're we're buddies you know
that's the hilarious I was like uhoh he
did not know my brother oh my God I was
like uhoh he's going to knock you out
dude knock you the [__] out which is
hilarious that's why I said don't do as
I do yeah it's very
Hazard Hazard L I walk around just
walking on landmines all the time dude
don't do what I do but once again like I
grew up very specific and you know this
was early on this was like I want to say
this is what I met Nate when you guys
just opened uh Fishbowl Studios back in
the day so that was a long that was 2014
a long time ago Dude so I would say like
2014 2015 dog 10 years ago yeah oh I
can't believe like oh it's been that
it's been that [__] long dude oh God
see I've I've grown now dude now we
wouldn't do that I would never do that
right yeah you never know who you're
talking to you can't just say any joke
yeah who knows what the they they're
going through it's just like times have
changed a lot dude like I've I've
definitely grown a lot since then and
I've would never do that but I don't
know man like I just I just thought I
don't know what I was
thinking there's no excuse here I don't
know what the [__] I was thinking dude
genius brain listeners this podast
podcast is brought to you by Magic mind
my friends how are you waking up in the
morning do you wake up in the morning
and you have a cup of coffee and it has
all that caffeine it goes into your
systems gives you the Jitter Jitter
Jitters and then you start crashing
later well guess what for me when I wake
up and usually when I'm doing something
pretty intense throughout the day
specifically mentally I take my magic
mind and I'm talking about before I
podcast so you guys don't know this
before I pod I usually take a shot of
magic mind uh and it's been really
really dope magic mind is just it's not
just like a boost of energy it has a
whole bunch of other stuff organic lines
man which supports attention cognitive
processing and working memory it has
ashwag gandha supports the reduction of
Stress and Anxiety look if you want to
go ahead and cop yourself some magic
mind uh do yourself a favorite and go to
magic mind.com and you could subscribe
and save up to 45% It's pretty dope once
again go to magic mind.com and be like
me start your day off with it and see
how much it changes your productivity I
freaking
love it so once again go to magic
mind.com and cop yourself some today
yeah and it was a long time ago and
you're a different person now you would
never call somebody no no no no no like
have you like you know what I think
about sometimes is like sometimes I just
want to go back in time and redo certain
things because of how embarrassing [__]
yeah stop yourself from doing some [__]
yeah I I would just go back it's like
hey don't do that like what are you
doing like specific some of the things
that I want to do and look I'm a married
man now I just want to go back in time
and reuck
somebody because of the just the
terrible dick that I gave them just cuz
the [__] worst I just want to go back
and be like that's not me you know I
could do so much better man that talk
that says how toxic I am cuz when I have
that imagination I'm just going back in
time to smack the [__] out of myself
yeah stop being
dumb I just didn't know right and it was
like specifically during this time time
where I felt like you know you would
just give terrible dick or whatever and
by the way I've received some terrible F
and vagina from women too right happens
to the best of us but nobody tells you
these things right so you just think
that everybody had a good time right and
so you're walking away feeling like
you're the [__] man and I go back and
I start reassessing things and I'm like
she did not have a good time yeah and I
found out you were in Euphoria I was in
Euphoria cuz at the time when you're
young if if it's if you're inside of
vene I'm doing it yeah it's happening
I'm like God is real no [__] way yeah
having sex out of wedlock me got me
closer to
God you know so I'm like going back I'm
like oh that was she was not enjoying
that at all was just starfish yeah it's
like why didn't she just say something
right I like maybe that was a little
fake or maybe I'm just overanalyzing
things but I knew this because cuz I
dated this one girl and she was super
[__] honest you know we were done I
was like how was it she was like
whatever and I was like excuse me [__]
I gave you my best move you know like
the part where I went in and then I went
out what else am I supposed to do what I
got I got nothing else up down left
right that's it that's my only move
that's all I got and then you know she
was just like yeah you just kind of like
just you know you just you're just
pumping and I'm like and in my mind I'm
like there's more like what what am I
I'm really young too and then she
started telling me about her preferences
what she likes and what she dislikes and
I'm like oh my God this one girl who by
the way was the most toxic woman I've
ever been with was the one that actually
helped get my dick game better right
because I was like oh there's things I
have to do why is it the crazy toxic
girls yeah they why is it the crazy
toxic I don't know but she changed my
[__] life dude cuz you know that
thing above my hole like that's that's a
clitter I was like what the [__] I
thought that was a speed bag [__] like
I had no idea like jelly beans yeah it's
like what the [__] you know she's like
telling me all these other things like
how to my hands like things like how she
was the first person that taught me how
to like you know just like the dirty
talk and [__] which I did not [__]
like and I told the story of the podcast
before where it's literally the most
embarrassing thing I've ever done I'm
bad at it too that's not my that's not
my game I like she I like a little bit
but she was kind of she was way more
sexually experienced than way she was
also 6 years older than me right and
so I hate telling the story but we were
in bed and then she was she was on top
and then she started dirty talking I've
never done this before right I just
figured out what a clitoris was right
and so she just goes like she went she
goes whose [__] is this and I went
[Laughter]
yours and then she stopped She was like
what I was like I don't
know whose else is it I didn't get a
receipt I don't know and then you know
then she was just like okay like we got
to talk about and then she start telling
me like okay know there's preferences or
whatever and she's the one who got me
into like dirty talking here and there
I'm not like all the you know I'm not
crazy with it but you know a few talking
here kind of turns me on a little bit
have you ever joked during sex and it
was just the wrong time oh plenty of
time that's that's like my number one
redo yeah like you know what I'm saying
I was hanging out with this girl this is
way back in Seattle and then um she was
like we're flirting and then she
mentioned my triceps she's like oh I
love like your triceps I like the shape
of that whatever hey that night you know
we're doing the deed and then she's
doing a little dirty talk and then I
tell a joke I was like yeah your triceps
are so [__] sexy and she went no oh
my God no and she pushed me off and
rolled over sometimes the jokes are
worth it though I'll tell you this dude
can I tell you this one never told
anybody this one it was a girl that I
was with I was hitting it from the back
and then she queefed right and then one
of my favorite movies of all time is
White Chicks yeah right so she did that
and I didn't fart back at her right but
I just went right back at you you know
like a white joke she was like what the
[__] and I was like you know
why are you thinking about these two
dude I've never seen a [__] get so dry
so fast in my life I didn't know that
that the liquid just could disappear
from that fast that [__] was dry as [__]
it felt like a it felt like a mechanic's
hand gripping my dick like it [__] was
so dry I ruined that moment so bad I was
like [__] but if I that's actually a
moment that I wouldn't go back in time
and change though because the joke was
worth it joke was worth I was completely
okay with it but yeah there's there's
just like things like when you're young
younger you don't you don't realize what
you're doing I was just I was amazed
that I got to see a vagina a vagine yeah
I was like oh my God this is [__]
real it's just like the pictures yeah
I'm like dude this is the [__] I
masturbated right and I see it in person
I'm like this is [__] insane just
like it's way different from the first
time you see a [__] yeah yeah I
remember looking at my first porno mag
like what that's that's what they have
like and then not it's like the anatomy
like they pee out and poop out of that
too like I I remember like just you know
after you hook up with your first person
you think all vaginas are going to look
like that vagina and then just they're
all different shapes sizes unique
fingerprint yeah it's a every girl's
vagina is a fingerprint it's very unique
I'm like this one has a lot of flaps
this one's a little darker this one's
lighter this one has no flaps that one's
pugie yeah I was like wow look at this
is [__] amazing I was actually kind
of shocked um what do you what do you
what do you do about hygiene
in terms of what when a girl shows up
unhygienic oh I've never had that never
had I've never had a girl who was dirty
like here's my thing too it's like
before whenever I hooked up with
somebody let's say like we they were at
my hotel or something I would watch
first and I think that would kind of set
a cue that she would want to watch too
so it would always start there yeah cuz
I don't know like I don't you don't know
where the [__] I've been you don't know
where the [__] youve been either so we
would just I would I would shower and
[__] I would clean my dick first right
and then she would just kind of join or
do whatever but that's typically what
would happen but I've never had like a
weird smelling vagina or any of that
stuff I've never had that
ever one
time one
time I don't even know if I should tell
just don't say
names I I went on a date and we had uh
what's that thing we ate with uh Robin
that oh the yanan that Chinese the
Korean Chinese yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
lamb lamb skewer lamb oh my God I
already know go ahead yeah we had that
for dinner and back at of her place I
was like did you take some to go oh my
God it smelled like lamb the exact same
thing we had just eaten oh really I
didn't know it was like that like is are
those spices that kind of potent I guess
I had no F I actually just found out on
my last podcast that you cannot get the
flu from somebody else through their
vagina H so you know you can just eat
the [__] out of it yeah apparently you
can I for some reason I thought that if
somebody has like the flu or a cult that
if you give them oral sex you shouldn't
do it but apparently you can't get it
like that interesting very fascinating
you're just going to find somebody with
the flu like I can't come over like oh
we can work it out we can work it out we
could we could figure this [__] out like
I don't know man like that's the things
too like I don't have a lot of regrets
but I definitely feel bad about just
like not knowing the female anatomy but
once again that's also because guys too
they don't ever when guys talk about
women when they're young young they only
talk about their Conquest they never
talk about the things they don't
know right yeah when I went out she's
[__] girl she was doing all this
other [__] I'm like damn that's all I
got to do to are we really paying
attention in sex ed when it comes to the
ovaries never I don't think the guys are
I'm just giggling yeah the whole time
exactly I'm at that they showed us a a
birthing video oh my God and yeah one
dude he got up from his desk and he went
to teacher she he was like uh I'm I'm
laded yeah can I go uh can I go to the
bathroom she's like all right and then
right there b in front of the TV and
there's like a baby coming out of this
guy passed the [__] out oh [__] yeah
dude that [__] was traumatizing when I
first saw it so much liquid and some
[__] yeah I didn't know shocking but I I
would have imagine now if I was trying
to push some [__] out of my conch like
would that [__] I heard a lot of women
are now opting to get a C-sections cuz
like the healing process is a lot EAS
easier and it's also safer for the baby
I would imagine just and preserve I mean
well from what I understand it zips
right back up like time the human body
is f it doesn't like stay the size of a
baby's [__] Cranium yeah yeah for
sure I mean the human body is amazing
I'm pretty sure it's going to feel a
little different your hips are a little
wider or whatever but I I don't know man
like when I talk to my female friends
and they let me know all this other
stuff about like child birth don't talk
to us about this [__] you know what I'm
saying they make it sound like it's the
most beautiful thing on no it's not it
is absolutely not will you be there in
the delivery room well Mariel's not even
sure she wants me there cuz I
scream I think she she's not sure if she
wants me there like be a distraction
like I told her like well if you get
pregnant like can I be there and she's
like I don't know if I want you there
she go you probably won't deal well with
this [__] I'm like first of all that's
[__]
offensive I mean I like are you so de
[__] disrespectful now I'm going to
be there yeah I'll scream my [__]
head out I don't give a [__] I mean I
was like what about me to hold your hand
she goes I don't know if I want you
there and I'm like dude this is very
disrespectful I'm just like talking to
her this is like the conversation we
just had like uh two weeks ago I'm like
the [__] what if I want to be there you
kick me out she goes probably like if
you can't handle it you're screaming I'm
like well I don't know if I'm going to
scream I might but I don't know but she
wasn't might pass out I might pass out
anything could happen it's like [__] and
just [__] flew it all over me I don't
know man eat the placenta dude people do
that though yeah I don't know what
that's about
the David Cho uhhuh uh the last time he
was on Rogan he's talking about how his
life changed because he's a multi-
multi-millionaire yeah he says he does
his rich people thing to do is buy
placentas and put them in a blender
every morning and drink it I feel like
David Cho now has gotten to the point
where like he
is he he kind of reminds me of the guy
that is so uninteresting he has to do
things that make him interesting he's
he's like becoming that guy now you know
what I mean he is but he's that type of
guy who will just about do anything
though yeah already as it is but then
it's it I do know what you mean like you
know you have to do this weird [__] now
yeah it's almost like I need something
to talk about let me do some weird
[__] [__] so I could talk about it I
think I mean but since his you know
cancellation quote unquote he's been out
of the I think he's been out of the the
line the news or whatever yeah I mean
good kind of keep to yourself you know
what I mean I mean it's just like a
weird space for me to like with David
Cho
like like I said I found him very
interesting all of his stories yeah but
now it kind of like ruins it cuz I was
like you're a habitual liar I don't know
if any of this is real I don't know what
you're saying is honest or real so it
kind of takes away from the fun of his
stories for him the whole world is just
a big show yeah and I think it's just
like we're all just the audience yeah
and it's kind of like that Andy Kaufman
idea of it doesn't matter if you're
laughing I'm laugh I'm dying inside
laugh yeah yeah yeah cuz he I I think
for him bombing is the funniest thing in
the world right and so he would
purposely do shitty comedy
yeah and so if you look back and um
Watch Andy Kaufman videos you would
think they're really bad like comedy but
then he sticks with it because inside to
him it's funny yeah right the difference
with that I understand the art aspect of
it I think the difference between Annie
coffin and David Cho is that David Cho
is actually seeking people's approval
right which is what he said like oh I
did this because uh people need to find
me interesting so like that kind of made
me lose a lot of respect for him I'm
like oh you're you're not an artist
you're a Tik
tocker like Gen X like without Tik Tok
yeah you're the Gen X without Tik Tok
you're doing anything and everything you
can to make people feel like you're
interesting and important so you just do
anything you just you're feing for
attention cuz the anti Coffman thing is
like I just do it for myself I don't
give a [__] whether you laugh or not I'm
enjoying myself for him he's like do you
like me do people think I'm interesting
do people think I'm weird oh maybe I
should say more weird [__] maybe I
should do more weird [__] it's like sad
yeah and it made me lose a lot of
respect for him cuz I just couldn't like
now I see him in a very different light
I'm like oh you're a dweeb you're a
[__] loser if I if I give him
the um benefit of the doubt of looking
at him as an artist not as an actor not
as a comedian not as a podcaster or
whatever that's he's an artist and if
his life and his behavior is his art I
respect it but maybe not my thing you
know I think people people will lose
that with whatever the [__] he's doing
because he does so so much random things
who knows what they're about because
it's quote unquote art that yeah maybe
it's the cycle of probably almost every
artist who gets into some certain age
where it's like we've seen it you see
what's next I got to do something bigger
and better but he can't he can't have an
online presence anymore because people
are going to attack him of course he
raped somebody it's like what do you how
do you come back from that you know what
I mean you openly said you raped a girl
like allegedly yeah yeah and then he
takes it back saying oh I was just
joking it's like okay dog like allegedly
yeah and he goes by the way I'm also a
liar it's like alleged yeah it's like
yeah it's like you could say anything
then like I don't know what anything is
real like you saying that this Li that's
why I'm saying it's just really he kind
of broke my heart a little bit you I
mean it's like uh before we move on
should we get into that celebrity
news no we don't have enough forgot
again well guys that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast uh
hope you guys enjoyed that I know we
didn't go deep into the one piece thing
that's the most I'm willing to talk
about it and it's just about animation
and general and how it translates I
don't think it does a very good job and
who knows who's going to do a good job
on this next hopefully next season will
be a lot better yeah oh I heard they're
making a one piece anime remake oh like
yeah so they're gonna consolidate it all
consolidate it like get rid of all the
[__] and the fillers and whatever
and do just adapt closer to the manga
but with modern animation oh that would
be [__] great I would love that 4K
let's [__] do that Tope ass animation
so that's coming like sometime soon yeah
yeah well genius spring every Sunday's
at 12:00 pm uh secret society s CTS o c
IE T y.com if you guys are in Wy ke make
sure you check out my matcha spot jumi
matcha is at the Royal Hawaiian you can
catch Ed at his podcast uh Bible study
at Momo and you can find me on Ed Park
VP on whatever socials genius BR every
Sunday at 1200 pm. we'll see youall next
time bye